and we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we are with
everybody
so you've been able to point the right
direction
oh Matthew stormy Young Harris damn it I
[__] it up at the end everyone said
hello
how are we all gentlemen
doing well
we've never had a girl I won't complain
we need something we need any girl hey
what are you doing
let's get heather in here
on camera right probably not all right
I'm gonna run the credits and we're
gonna get on with this
[Music]
before we talk aliens which we are going
to talk aliens
um somebody dropped a interesting little
um article I think it's from Collider
uh no cbr.com best top Sci-Fi series in
the noise
and I just wondered what you guys
thought of it um I've not even seen a
couple of these Series so we're going to
start off with like I don't know but in
at number 10 have you guys ever see a
series called Invader Zim on
Nickelodeon's cartoon
um
probably about eight at this point
though right yep it fit my bill pretty
well yeah Matt you've seen it I've seen
it I didn't die hard but you watched
Invader Zim on
I have seen die hard
[Laughter]
I watched it because you told me you
took the piss out of me for not watching
it yeah
because it's a cartoon when I was a kid
obviously when I was a kid I was beyond
that for me but number nine that was
2001 by the way number nine 2007 a
series called Tin Man
didn't watch that either uh four half
hour mini series broken for three parts
I like the sound of it
was in it I quite like to do so but yeah
was this a uh uh a Sci-Fi series yeah
but it looks kind of like a western
uh four-part ministers demonstrating
fantasy cook combined with science
fiction it was like a Wizard of Oz okay
down the road yeah I think I've seen it
well number eight Sanctuary
2008. I I did watch that
so that's a good that's a good shot
now guys I go I championed this show and
I don't think any of you guys have
watched it but Warehouse 13 at number
seven aired in 2009
it's great Sci-Fi show it was the first
the first season in particular was
brilliant
do you guys ever watch it I don't think
you did it
yeah I've only ever heard good things
yeah it's good sir uh number six
Terminator the Sarah Connor Chronicles
well a couple of episodes
uh I really like that I like the Sarah
Connor Chronicles yeah it was really I
was really getting into it and I got
canceled it was annoying number five a
show that just wouldn't get canceled
even though
um I don't think I ever I caught a
couple of episodes here and there but
um I think it was the Sci-Fi networks
Eureka it was on 2000. oh yes Rica
just a cop living by a crazy town full
of psycho scientists that get trying to
blow everybody up from what I remember
Wheaton was in it also
yeah well number four finally
finally
Stargate Atlantis aired in 2004. whoop
beautiful and how that's not number one
I don't know until you realize at number
three
is 2002's Firefly
come on
just finished it I love it Harris you're
about to get excited oh I know I know
they jump around and go I told you so I
told you so
but 1999's so I don't really noticed
um but yeah
Futurama is a number two
Sci-Fi show ever made
um but this one interested me because
it's in 2005 doc to who
now would that be when David Eccleston
returned
yeah when it got rebooted so yeah I
would argue that was the best Doctor Who
in years when we had those five those
few years with ecclestone and then
tenants and then Matt Smith what do you
think about that list guys off top your
head
I like it having having Doctor Who is
number one makes me happy boy and I'm
gonna stroke stroke
we're only on here for five minutes and
we're already jacking off and 10 inch is
already back the record it is a new
record
that's so happy about it
um right I just don't I just thought I
thought I thought that's quite an
interesting list I thought as Atlantis
deserve to be a little higher but the
three shows above it except for Futurama
deserve to be there but nothing to put
allows us about Doctor Who yeah anyway
at least one of my favorite shows won
so we are here to talk about UE fees uh
UFOs aliens visiting years
um before we get stuck into it I was
hoping to get like a bit of an idea of
what we actually think about the UFO
phenomenon if we can agree a few things
before we get stuck into it
so first of all should we just accept
that we are not the only life in the
solar system and sorry in the universe
right can we we all know there's life
elsewhere right
we can make a logical conclusion that
there would be for me we don't know for
certain it's a thing but everywhere we
go on Earth that we look for life even
inside volcanoes and stuff we find life
so I would I honestly believe there'll
be life within the solar system it'll
just be like bacterial so isn't there
bacterial life in the ice on Mars and
didn't we find microbial life in the
skies of Venus
it was um it was it was like the fossil
eye products
okay
biological process
essentially they're looking at method
like
in the Clouds of Venus they again
they've seen the byproducts haven't they
they're looking at methane they're
looking at alien farts yeah alien farts
is what we want
um that's how we're going to find it
we're going to find alien farts or alien
rubbish basically so we're probably
going to find the evidence first so
um
the interesting thing about the you know
you were talking about volcanoes and so
forth those are called extremophiles and
the interesting thing is we you know
just
until we discovered those volcanic vents
on the ocean we thought no there's
nothing
can live in sulfuric acid you know
that's that's above the boiling point
that can't happen and here we have whole
ecosystems here on Earth nowhere near
light the only energy source is the heat
from the volcanic Vents and so and
that's been there a while that's not the
new thing that just suddenly evolved I
mean also there's um uh there are uh
uh under
underwater caving systems where
um extremophiles have evolved uh that
have been sealed away for a very long
time that have been discovered and
they're they're found nowhere on Earth
they're just in these isolated pockets
of underground caverns and water so
if these really remote places sprinkled
around even Earth
and it's in single-celled organisms was
the first thing to pop up on Earth
you know other moons and planets in the
solar system has been cooking for just
as long as Earth has and especially
Enceladus which is you know is is a
water planet with a crust of ice I think
the chances are quite good to find life
in the solar system it's a really awful
chart huh there's some extrema files
that they found the spores for and they
estimate they were something like three
million years old so they were sort of
like it was one of those dig deep dig
things they found so they dig a hole
like three miles down and they found
these extremely fastables
while they were sort of like testing
them and experimenting the bloody things
cracked open yeah alive
millions of years have been sat there
the scientists must be like I if I was
on the scientist so like I think this is
how the Earth ends I've seen Sci-Fi
movies we're all [__] these things
come alive and they're going to jump at
them
we're gonna dig up some space
I think that's really how it's gonna
happen
um right so so we can agree life almost
certainly is X Alpha in the universe I
can we also agree though that
intelligent life is probably incredibly
rare
probably
most likely I don't know the universe
right so where we are in the universe
and where where Earth is situated and
when we came to be
on the cosmological scale kind of thing
we we can we arrived pretty late
yeah 100 000 years old roughly yeah so
look at where we are now and look at all
the universe is there could have been
civilizations that have
Rose to power Fallen like 10 times
but what I mean is like relatively
speaking even though there may be
millions of intelligent species that
have existed when you're looking at a a
universe that's got two trillion stars
and two trillion unit and galaxies and
you know loads even if there's one or
two intelligent species existing at a
point in time per Galaxy they're still
going to be four trillion intelligent
species so they still look crapload but
I mean yeah compared how many stars
there are though they're probably quite
rare
yeah because it's gonna have to be
situated in a well for life is what you
know it in the Goldilocks zone but
that's not to say as as you were just
talking about with your extrema files
there's different forms of life that
exist in different conditions which
we'll never interact with because they
can't they can't
um
build radios no not they can't build
radios they can't survive in our
conditions so they've got no reason to
come to us kind of thing
if you look at IO I mean it's all sulfur
and gases and boiling
and so why not there I mean if any
exists why not uh IO
um
one one thing I read that was an
interesting concerning um
the starting of life
there's this uh scientist that looked at
it from a thermodynamic point of view
almost that if you
[Music]
um if you didn't have
cellular organisms organizing atoms and
becoming molecules it would almost
violate the law the laws of
thermodynamics I read that he was
basically arguing that it's it's almost
inevitable yeah for at least basic life
to exist anywhere that there's at least
water
and going on about intelligent species I
would say there's plenty of intelligent
species on Earth I mean now we are King
Modi but you know dolphins are really
smart that they just can't make tools
well they're really smart they just
can't make tools with me because if they
could man they wouldn't be a boat in the
water
I mean Dolphins orcas whales they're all
so smart that we can't even actually
gauge their intelligence there are five
different Apes in the Stone Age there
are otters in the Stone Age and then
there are also
Birds uh like like parrots and Ravens in
the Stone Age and I can remember stuff
up to like what a five to seven year old
human being
um yeah we're not alone in our
intelligence we just happen to be a
little further along or questing or
peaking
hopefully not until we boil ourselves to
death
about
how much of space we've actually seen
and the analogy was essentially take a
glass of water from all of our oceans in
the world they all imagine the
university is as our oceans on Earth you
fill up a glass of water that's how much
of space we've seen or we've observed
and we're going is there any fish in
that glass of water
obviously not
it's everywhere else
like I found an interesting
I like that analogy it's really good and
then it's quite recently we've realized
that because of the way the universe is
expanding there's loads of it we can't
see and can never see because it's
beyond because the light will never
reach us because it's expandative and I
didn't quite get me around it but I was
like oh that's interesting
um
they've apparently seen the literal
start of the universe yeah they found it
which we all know is where the Ancients
radio signal came from
up ahead of the Ancients that's why
those Destiny guys are out there looking
and trying to think but um okay so are
we are we in agreement though that we're
not talking about whether life exists
we're not religious people here that
believe the youth it's only six thousand
years old and that the Bible is actually
historically accurate all the way
through it's a circular in places before
you have a go at me but um we're talking
about whether aliens are then visiting
Earth
so obviously we've had these um
Congressional Senate hearings I I said
Senate I think in my video the other day
and I got told off
not actually gone to Congress yet
Lords or whatever you want to call them
and it's going to the Congress yeah
um that's don't laugh with us we don't
know
I had to make a little you still have a
presidential system it isn't even
democracy so don't laugh at us oh it
never was
hahaha
that's sort of oh that's a whole other
four hour video dudes
all right so
they've had they've had these little
conversations with these three guys um
and that's what that's really why always
triggered this conversation so David
grush
um Tim I know Timber Shay was one of the
um Republicans David fraver who is
somebody I am very interested by and
Ryan Graves
so first of all have you guys seen sort
of some of some of the conversations
we're going on this week happened
Wednesday yes yeah I think a lot of the
the first name you mentioned a lot of
his
um
whatever you were saying is there other
interviews
evidence evidence yeah Denise possession
so first of all actually before we get
into that sorry I meant to say so just
very quickly if we go around the tiles
do you actually believe aliens are
visiting the Earth are you a you know a
beluga or are you a denier so Matt do
you believe it is I believe yeah
simply yes how is where it gets
complicated okay and stormy bear seen
them twice
okay well I'm going to be the
um skeptic and I will say that I used to
believe that UFOs are visiting years and
then I had a mystery and conspiracy
Channel where I actually did sort of
research it quite a lot and now
I'm not convinced
um I I would lean towards that guy that
British guy whose name has just come out
my head
it was it was full of crackers but he
said that 95 of UFO sightings are
completely explainable there's five
percent though that are that are worth
investigating I would agree with that
and I I do think that but I think is
I've just seen so much evidence now and
then when she gets stuck into it you
just realize this is this is just
nonsense
um what is that Robert Cooper in his
story and the more you dig into it it
sounds it'll sound so believable on the
surface but you dig into him
and he's just he's a
broad line of criminal but anyway we'll
go into that
um later
um so I'm I'm a little bit more
skeptical but only because of the rest
of the reason I stopped doing the
conspiracy Mystery Channel was because I
suddenly realized I don't believe most
of this
and I was starting to it was starting to
depress me so I stopped
um so I'm a little bit more skeptical
but I have seen stuff in the sky that I
can't explain
I'm more than one occasion
so I will anyway so
David grush
an ex-intelligence analyst a
whistleblower apparently
um he was in charge of a DOD Department
that looked that was in charge of
basically trying to gather alien
technology from what I can see until
2003 start 2003
and he says he's not seen it himself but
he has spoken to people and the US
government either have partial or intact
alien spacecraft
and apparently non-human bionics
so I found this [__] about something
about our uh American Congress
you know the one of the congressmen when
she was asking well you know
what about the pilots there's really any
pilot Circle yes we have biologics you
know and um
they never asked that no one asked the
next question if they're biologics well
were they carbon-based or silicon-based
I mean it just drives me to distraction
I mean can you imagine if they are
silicon-based I mean
the the fact that there's that that the
American Congress is so science
illiterate that just seems to me like it
was well what do we know about I mean
are they
I mean do do they have hearing I mean
you know
can you imagine
if they have a culture that has
something like a an alien Stephen King
you know I mean what kind of culture did
they how do they use it I mean there's
all these tracks of questions that you
can ask that would have I think he
wasn't answering that was that he was
saying look I can't say that because
it's still classified yeah he said was
there anything on that spacecraft I
would say that's classified did you see
into biologics oh no no they're
non-biological board like oh you just
asked that question said you've got an
answer and then you've answered it
anyway but he was he was very very
careful I think it's fair to say
yeah you couldn't go into specifics
because of this whole
um whistleblower protection thing but
that's a really new thing for military
whistleblowers and he he's under I think
what he said he's pending investigation
like the whole thing is pending
investigation and
basically I guess to see if he's going
to get court-martialed or not
button excuse me
well I mean others would I mean you know
favor
he you know he got permission to come
out and just spill the beans I mean he
this is the whole Tic Tac video is
really what started the whole you know
Slow Burn Disclosure thing well his
mission was never classified was it so
he was able to report on what he'd seen
um David frave is I think one of the
most interesting
um
things I like right if you look at
things like the Betty Barney Hill story
Betty and Barney Hill changed their
story over time
and you've got other you want to say I
mentioned Robert Cooper earlier he
changed his story over time it evolved
which is never good the
guy that was in charge at the British
UFO event
um again sorry I forgotten his name
um Over The Air Base
anyway he changed his time loads of
times sorry nothing go ahead oh okay
David fravor has never changed his story
he keeps it really it's really simple
it's really specific it's never changed
he's never like tried to evolve the
story to make it more interesting and
more exciting
um he he I think he's a very very
believable eyewitness
and an expert eyewitness which is well
interested if he says he sees an alien
aircraft that does something that it
physically not possible to do with our
current technology like that that's
interesting because he knows what
aircraft can do
so but what do you guys think about
David fraver generally is and Ryan
Graves who's a very similar sort of
eyewitness a pilot that has actually
seen these things is that important is
it important that these Witnesses are
actually eyewitnesses they know what
they're looking at I think
the hardest thing to take Rush seriously
is the the the the the layer of
skepticism that we are like even allowed
to put onto it because he can't give us
specifics
I understand the lack of being able to
give public specifics to a degree and he
does say like in the whole hearings and
stuff like okay well we can talk about
this like behind closed doors kind of
deal like okay cool but
are you gonna like discount everything
you said behind closed doors in 20
seconds or is it going to be an
elaborate description of everything we
just asked about silicon-based life
forms or whatever you know and we have
no way of knowing that I guess uh and of
course you can't really like
tease us either which way you know it's
it's not a TV show it's it's
Congress and stuff but the the that
layer of of skepticism that's still
allowed
I think without firsthand Witnesses
doesn't help the case
but I I agree you know we at least you
know us four we really want the detailed
you know the low down the drill you know
the the the Deep dive into it we want to
see the the science articles we want to
read the abstracts all of that I want
the autopsy video and he and he wants
the autopsy not only probably doesn't
want the autopsy video he probably wants
the Frozen Corp so he can poke at it
with a stick you know how mad is but I
wanted to oh well not that one but one
thing you would just barbecue the
[__] thing and try to make it
hey if it tastes good I gotta know
I'm supposing a text
slow roasted on a Traeger grill for like
23 hours I'm a happy freaking camper
we're gonna see if it's a tender tough
if it's gamey if what it is it's gonna
be good this whole thing about
skepticism with it right
I am pretty skeptical
but
I'm always skeptical when I hear about
UFOs because I think most people are
crazy most people are just idiots they
don't know what they're seeing right he
builds space this guy is from the
military
what reason has he got to lie and it's
not just him it's three other people and
it's been other people throughout the
years as well who have said it from the
military what reason have they got
it's a lie because it's the
if it's true they're putting their lives
in danger
if it's false
what are they getting out of it
they're just taking them off as pension
I'm kidding no he doesn't have a reason
why I don't think and in the most uh
steadfast I say but people do like other
whistleblowers they they always you know
they like you know Jimmy's saying they
don't change your story
um you know like some of these you have
to be you have to be skeptical I think
because we all of us are on Facebook
we've seen the [__] that gets pushed
on Facebook every single day
um and like Carl Sagan said you know
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and this is an
extraordinary claim you know so
I mean I'm not here to crucify the guy
or any of these gentlemen
um especially the military guys it's
just we have to look cautiously at what
we're being told we have to I mean like
us we're getting together on a Sunday to
see okay do we believe it where's the
holes or whatever
you know but um
a lot of times I keep going back and
a lot of the most CR here's the thing
for me and and uh all the and let's just
dump in all the people that have offered
testimony to Dr Greer's uh disclosure
projects right
um
they all tell the same story and they're
all kind of parallel stories you know
all these generals and Admirals and
fighter pilots and and and
um
and and just people that are in the CIA
where we're in CIA or we're in FBI or
whatever
of if you take the the the
amalgam of all the really credible
people
they're all kind of telling the same
story maybe different pieces of the
story but it's all parallel you know I
mean even
um even Bob Lazar I mean it's just you
know we're still waiting for someone to
come out and just oh this is here's the
ultimate truth of the why he's full of
[__] but you know he's part of that
parallel thing you know um let me talk
about Bob Lazar for a bit
um his stories because
you know how I feel about Bob
I know how you feel about Bob but I
don't care
so I
think Brett has I've been reading his uh
book Dreamland right
and I reading it I've kind of come I've
kind of solidified my conclusion about
him is he somewhere on the autism scale
if you read his book it's like oh yeah
okay that and that explains a lot you
know but the best line there you oh I
love that book so here's the the best
line from the book I found
and I'm quoting bubbles right here
I've always had a bit of arsonist in me
not so much as a prankster but as an
agitator
and this book is full of so many Little
Gems like that
but you know it's um he goes into a
really deep dive about his experience
there leading up and he really put it
into words that no one can really kind
of misquote and it's got a really
beautiful
um
uh frequency
who still believes it but anyway even
though the corkiness and the hookers and
the video cameras and the fireworks and
the smoke bombs and the hydrogen cars
and all the other [__] he was into
um
his story huh
what oh yeah
um
he uh he had the jet car and there's
like the hydrogen of the the Corvette
that was converted to a hydrogen that he
used in his uh his VHS
Bob Lozada does it matter that he has
been caught repeatedly
telling things saying things that then
aren't true
[Music]
his education is a problem
well is it is educational is the problem
or
is it true you know so he he got the he
got the education someplace
so where did he go
the problem is though that he then says
he went to sort of like MIT and other
people that went said they never heard
of him he said he met certain
um professors and the professor said
they've never heard of him
um
um well other people have actually now
come out and since said I actually took
him to MIT so I don't know what you're
on about I gave him a lift
but maybe they're just trying to support
him
um because he's now quite a big
celebrity there are issues with this
story
but they're not his issues it's like why
can't the college reproduce his records
yes that's true
and and he if he would not be the first
person
that comes out that has been disappeared
by the educational system
yep I mean hell I've had credits lost by
you know and by Wake Forest University
you know I have receipts from classes I
took and they have no recollection of it
I mean one of the interesting things was
he said I worked over at um it wasn't
Area 51 it was the other place wasn't it
the um yeah and he basically said I
worked there and they said no he didn't
they said didn't they say no he didn't
like two years yeah somebody found the
phone directory yeah and there is this
there's his name so that helped with his
credibility a lot so it's the things
that um I mean he can claim something
right I get that you know and there's
discrepancies but he's not the one
creating the discrepancies I guess is my
point you know if you're looking at you
know as as a logic tree
you know so where's the breakdown you
know it's
um it's the colleges which have
especially MIT which have enormous
federal grants and Loans especially in
from the military from DOD
you know at that time when his life was
clearly being threatened
um
that they would just you know do
anything they could to discredit him and
they have
I mean can you imagine the amount of
money they've spent on just trying to
discredit Bubbles are
when he's been saying the very same
thing now that other whistleblowers that
we now treat is credible that maybe
don't have autism that actually got a
job in the military
you know and
um
I mean hell even the IRS admitted that
yeah that's his pay stub from the office
from the naval Office of Intelligence
so I mean you know it is so was he uh
was he sweeping the floor as it S4
maybe it's
at some point in time somebody you know
looked up his educational record said
yeah you're our boy and by the way
here's here's uh nine spacecraft that we
have told nobody about
yeah they was just trying to get
somebody that thought out of the box and
one thing you can definitely say about
Bob Bazaar is he thinks out of the box
um he's not a normal like scientist he's
not a prankster is
alien technology and stuff you want
somebody that thinks that isn't
we should be suspicious but in that
things like when he's on Joe Rogan he
starts getting specific questions you'll
also get to migraine and maybe you
stressed whatever but that that didn't
come across gray it didn't help but
that's also uh here's the how the book
looks
but it's also you know that's a feature
of autism stress
uh anxiety especially in social
situations
but if you read the book and and just
kind of look at it well is this written
by someone that's autistic I mean
there's lots of two there's lots of road
flares in there it's like
now I kind of
paranoia and it's one of the things was
like I said he um he got raided by the
FBI and they say no it's because of the
documentaries because of the documentary
and then it turned out it's because
you've been sending radioactive material
across state lines
which was a little bit of a problem
because he'd got that he put a science
pack together it was supposed to be a
toy but one of the things was it had
radioactive material in it to do
experiments with and he'd been shipping
it all over the country just after 9 11.
yeah the FBI raided him and yet the FBI
lied about why they were there
they were looking for a receipt for
somebody that got something
they didn't challenge them on the uh the
uh his stalking of trentonite or
whatever
the FBI if they're asked a straight
question their automatic responses to
lie about it everything are you the FBI
wait a second
they like so okay so the other big name
that you mentioned then was Dr Stephen
Greer so again we're talking about The
credibility of the UFO experience
incredible
I I would agree with that I would agree
with that but when I phrased that I said
the people he brought forward in his
disclosure project not Greer I'm not
talking about career I think
I think there was some really there were
some very credible Witnesses
particularly in the first disclosure
project and there's some very incredible
ones but if you let everybody step
forward you're going to get some notice
and some pharmacists yeah but yeah the
the the Admirals and like I said the
Admirals the generals the CIA guys I
think all those dudes are really CR the
people he brought forward were really
credible and especially in this other
round which is just more of the same as
we saw on the uh
yeah I'm not talking about Greer just
want to make sure I'm not talking about
Greer I'm the people he brought forward
for the first disclosure project and
then the most recent one which is uh two
three months ago I mean all these guys
are military dudes and it's still the
same parallel story
I mean at some point time you just gotta
say okay fine
they're here now what the creatures
he comes out and says I've personally
got I've been I've been offered 20
billion dollars to
um not tell you about this power thing
that I've got that I'm going to tell you
about and we're going to produce 20
years later I was offered 20 billion
dollars for that one you should have
[__] took it then because you've not
told anything about it
um it's just like your tit he's a con
artist he's I've done this video and
it's free and I've not made any money on
this and then we're going to his tax
returns because yes you did
because yeah you've got one company that
produced it but then and that made no
money and it was crowdfunded basically
but then the production company that
actually made it that you this that you
paid to produce a company you own as
well and that company America
accompanied loads of money and they kept
all the profits you did make a load of
money producing these documentaries
because you're the only the production
company you're the only employee
so I just wish if if is is just a bit of
a con artist and that just to me that
then you've got to question everything
else he does when you start realizing
that unfortunately
he lies uh allegedly because I don't
want to get sued
um these things so that just that's
infuriates me when I research these
things and you look into it really
critically you find out that these big
names in these things are not as
trustworthy as you think and they're
selling snake oil and when you start
thinking like that you start you have to
start questioning the other stuff they
start talking about
well again you know it's
um I want to be sure that I'm really
clear about this I I'm giving um
legitimate credit to the guys he brought
forward the generals and the Admirals
that have that have experienced this has
been like the the there's the latest one
uh there was a uh I think it was an F4
pilot
that was uh chased by a UAP
and
um
they're and there's corroborating
evidence about this and he finally
brought the guy and the guy came forward
yeah and uh so it's those and they said
they're telling the same story that
favor did and the guys back in the 20
years ago right after or right before 9
11 in the first disclosure project it's
still the it's the the witnesses I guess
and I would not count Greer as a witness
Lee you're not getting a timeout I don't
care how much you try to distract me
with your comments we're not giving your
time out you're a very hashtag probe the
cattle throw the cattle baby well I we
should talk about Capital mutilations
considering that um Harris is here
um
how many of your cousins have been
um a probe 17 and a half
but there's there is that question
though that why are aliens coming all
the way here to mutilate our cattle and
I think obviously that's a nonsense
thing but why do you
Matt aliens are coming all this way why
on Earth would they be coming here why
I like the idea that
um the planet that we're on is kind of
like a zoo
there's so many species here yeah we're
the most dominant one
um but even if even if they're not here
to look at other things if they're here
to just look at us
like
we're pretty damn interesting look at
all the cultures around the different
around the world
like you've got the west and then you've
got the the like the Asian culture and
you've got Chinese culture as well and
you've got what's happening in Russia
and North Korea like all this all this
different we're one species we should
all buy rights just all do the same
thing but we don't
and that's interesting and they would
probably see that as well
you just made me think of something I
would not get into politics or anything
on the store but just like our our
species culturally still has because we
tend to just politically and and we're
just a tribal species that tends to like
go one or the other one or the other
even though there's always four five six
seven different perspectives context
whatever
we're really Eastern or Western
ideologies and there are a lot of like
sub-ideologies within each one of those
principles per se but we are literally
just Eastern or Western ideals typically
I wonder if we're interesting because
we're in that gray area between being
very regionally uh
regionally aligned and then a future era
where we are like Matt was talking about
we are just one species one culture you
know and I I mean if you look at how the
world is now with the internet and what
it was like in like 1975 completely
different
the
funny story not really important to any
of the things we're talking about but
this is back in the days of AOL right so
I was bored out of my mind and I was in
the NASCAR chat and I was talking to
this one guy
it is like it was a seven getting around
seven eight o'clock Eastern time at
night
and um we're just chatting you know
about NASCAR [__] which is really
pertinent to the American South at that
time of course and the guy said well I
gotta go I gotta go to work and I said
well are you second shift someplace it
says no
no I'm first shift I said well the sun's
going down they say well no the sun's
coming up I said well where the hell are
you at I'm in Perth
Australia and here's the Australian
getting up getting ready to go to work
and talking on AOL about NASCAR and I
have no clue
or he's at on in on the surface of the
Earth none we found one topic that we
had in common and that was NASCAR of all
the [__] things
so that's when I knew the internet was
going to be really big and bring people
together I mean look there's I know
Jamie and Matt and I would not have met
them through the uh
yeah it's amazing well look me and Jay
me and Jay live relatively close to each
other which is weird yeah
we would never have but yeah we would
never have known each other had it not
been for the internet
that's it's my favorite thing about
having a YouTube channel I guess
somebody just messaging me going yeah
Australian anything all over the world
uh you know Kerry and everybody that
comes in Canadians you you two idiots
on on from doing YouTube
so back in 2009 when I was YouTuber when
I had hair and I was like a nice sexy
like
anyway
when I was sexier uh she was like my fan
and like
I fancied her but I would never
basically my point is I would never have
met my misses never have my kids I have
now never had the life I have now have
the Internet it's mental if it weren't
for your fans of course
yeah
I don't like to say that I have fans now
and I always joke that she was my number
one fan girl
um she was your groupie literally but
really yeah I mean I had like what 2 000
subscribers back then which was a lot
back then but
I've never slept with any of the fans
off Sidetrack what the hell that's where
you're going wrong oh come on his wife
hates it it didn't happen in New York
they weren't waiting for you
no not one no
so I mean with just just us for here you
know trying to
I mean with eight billion people it'll
take generations for us to all
become a global civilization I mean we
have a global economy but that doesn't
mean we're all civilized you know it
says because many of us do not have an
opportunity educational opportunities
um or the language skills or the money
to even I mean still there's a lot more
people on planet Earth
they don't even know what the internet
is they could never conceive of it you
know so we do have a ways to go but and
it's going to be a slow ass process
[Music]
um
to get back to the UFO phenomenon though
sure
that's why that's why we're here
um
I actually think these three guys are
actually really credible Witnesses I
think they're some of the most credible
Witnesses we've had in the last time
not you dot David fravor even Ryan
Graves and this David
Groucho everyone Dr Badger Dr Al and Dr
Fox we got this [__] apparently
um
is there has there been a change in the
last decade
with UFO research that it's gone from
being in
um
some of the only tin foil hats people
did you know in the back of their RV
um you know smell the weed weirdly and
um you know and they're just crazy is it
actually becoming
serious
oh I think so I think it's probably more
the fact that there's so much
information out there now with the likes
of YouTube taken off over the last 10
years I know YouTubers existed for more
than 10 years but really took off over
the last 10 years like online streaming
online just building communities
like prior to 10 years ago that wasn't
as easy as it is now
so people who were interested
started getting into it and then they
they realize that they're actually good
at it and then they become like
professional UFO Hunters
it's kind of like like us like we're
but we're not professional anything but
we started making videos
and now we
do it every bloody week yeah
professional rocket Builder technically
right well I mean taking it I mean here
I mean one day
why did that fail that nut that we let
can he only had one job it's tighten one
Bolt
oh we're not going to Titanic I'm
guaranteeing you that
but one thing I've also noticed is the
reception of people on social media
it's like the most interesting response
I've seen in the last couple days is oh
there's aliens so I'm not paying my
[__] school loans
you know and so you
it takes repeat
people to testify before Congress before
anyone
gets it into their head that all this is
a thing it's like an advertising you
usually have to present an ad three to
five times to to somebody before they
actually pay attention to it and that
was like that's that it was like 20
years ago I don't who knows how many
times you got to repeat an ad to
somebody because we're all so immune to
it and so for something big like a
congressional hearing not everyone's
going to look at it not everyone's going
to pay attention I mean those people are
so disconnected from politics at least
here in America they have no idea what's
going on with anything
but if they can't get it in 50 seconds
they're not going to watch it anyway
exactly who wants to sit down for a
three-hour test you know Congressional
uh meeting it's a good thing Tech talk
exists because Tick Tock has taken all
of these little
like bite-sized like nuggets of
information in runs millions and
millions of years
and then getting the information who who
otherwise would never have sat down and
watched the hour two hour long video
they might now because they're like oh
actually interested in that because they
keep seeing like little bits here and
there it's like the Amber Heard and the
um Johnny Depp case lots of people
wouldn't sit there and watch the entire
thing but they would watch little clips
about what's happened and they'd be up
to date on the news because it's a
really good point were you watching some
Amber Heard Johnny Depp Clips the other
day or something
no it's just the most recent thing that
was a good example I've just had to ask
the question it was a cultural event
that turned Global because of uh social
media oh yeah there's a YouTuber that
did very well off me for about three
months watching that and then as soon as
it was done I realized he was an idiot
so I immediately disabled his channel
and stopped watching something else but
he was he was actually pretty good
that wasn't you disabled his channel I
bought his channel yes no no you said I
disabled his channel i i i unsubscribed
um and yeah and um unsubscribing doesn't
disable someone's Channel yeah it did oh
well thank God because um
hang on hang on let me quickly
unsubscribe
the lights went out real quick though
Lee Wilcox brought up a really good
point in the chat the only reason
America is holding the truth back is the
aliens are stupid and they picked
America to crash land in but that's not
necessarily the point
but why do we see
so much more of an alien presence quote
unquote if there is one in the US versus
globally of course there is still plenty
of stuff globally but I feel like so
much of it is just
focally pointed at the us or or we're
the ones leaking it or we have someone
whistle blowing it or wherever you know
there's literally hundreds of countries
across the globe
why not anybody else
country on the planet which I think is
probably the most technologically
advanced country on the planet it's
fancy other than you know like China and
China but
um they just don't have as many as much
Tech in all of their citizens hands per
se I would think like South America has
constant some of the most important you
know UFO sites in South American there's
loads
um I don't know about many in Africa but
but I think the more we get quite a lot
in Europe though as well I mean some of
the most important UFO sightings in
history came from you the one possible
to the crossfits
um Air Base site in it's only about 10
miles that way from me
um and that's one of the most important
sightings we've ever had because it was
actually corroborated by loss and it was
the next day was the big um Belgium
sighting which was basically within 12
hours there was this baked of UFO
sightings and it crossed a big line
basically it went from uh there's a an
air base just south of here and then
CrossFit and then Belgium it's in a
straight line with each other so if
something went through the sky it was
around the time stealth bombers were
being um did a lot but
um you just made me think with just
saying that though what what do you
think like internationally what is the
most compelling I think case just like
the individual case that's people or an
individual has come up with I think uh
because the one that comes to mind for
me would be is it South Africa that had
that entire Schoolhouse yes I think
that's the most compelling case that
I've ever heard and it's
a hundred people 100 plus right people
that saw that so
I don't know that's the most compelling
thing I've ever heard yo y'all anymore
he's a weird case and you know there's
sometimes these cases you think well I
could imagine a scenario where that
could be something else like
when the X-Files first came out flying
sources were popular we went fashionable
for a bit they all became triangular and
then a couple of years after that we
realized over stealth problems I think
and people saw that aircraft because it
doesn't pay like a normal aircraft it
hasn't got you know like you don't
there's no vent it's weird shaped it's
you know when it was secret and nobody
knew that aircraft existed some people
saw them
triangular UFOs became a thing for a bit
so sometimes you hear these things you
think I can imagine a scenario where
this could be something else the school
thing
a bunch of kids just made up a story and
stuck with it for 30 years
but that's a lot of kids to stick with
one story I'm familiar with this one
what's the story so it's basically a
school in South Africa and um that they
say a UFO literally landed in the
playground
um a UFO got off I believe
um I'm only vaguely remembering this I
have to admit
um and didn't it speak to them
it's I think it said something or it
spoke to like a speaker or something but
like it said or they heard something I
don't know if it spoke to them but it
could have like played them on music or
a message or whatever but it was you
know uh schoolhouses out there aren't
like
they truly divided by every age so it's
like all ages of kids there's like 100
kids and all the school teachers and I
believe there were people from outside
of South Africa that were there at the
school too and there's like just a
couple other because there was a whole
different like
group of witnesses it was like different
age stage of life everything different
professions all kinds of stuff the
customers from the kids and adults were
remarkably the same telepathically
showed them Armageddon is what there's
magic and science said I don't I don't
remember the Armageddon part of it I
think they would not be joking
it was a telecast something but I don't
remember
I thought you meant the movie
but it doesn't mean the movies I really
didn't show them a film they came in and
were like we really like this movie
[Music]
the alien singer or did they actually
get Aerosmith in their brains yeah they
got Aerosmith
um but I think that's a fascinating sign
we're talking about evidence though the
most recent evidence is the probably The
Tick Tock the Gimbal and the Speedster
videos yeah most famous the Pentagon
have said we don't know what these are
eyewitnesses like David favor didn't
record any of these videos but what he
basically did said was he was actually
on a mission earlier in the day he saw
what would be the tick tock
anything and then when he was got back
onto the carrier he said then these
other Pilots were going out and he said
oh while you're out there look for these
things this is what we've seen and one
of them recorded it and that's what the
tick tock video is
well there's a lot of YouTube videos out
there though that trying to debunk those
videos and say that they're other things
um
and a lot of them are very convincing
Corridor cruise is one of the best ones
of those
yeah but it's all about
um if it's on Tick Tock it must be true
um but that's ignoring the human element
though isn't it the same like okay I
know in a crime the human eyewitness is
the worst evidence
but when you've got somebody like David
fraver
who is who is an expert witness
can you just ignore what he's saying
uh here's the other thing another thing
that was not uh brought up
or or other questions were asked
follow-up questions were asked I can't
remember it was the other it wasn't
favor favor it was the other uh pilot
uh he said yeah there's so many of these
things now that a lot of people just
have you know uh warnings about UAP and
they're in their daily briefings
I mean and no follow-up to that is oh
damn where's that second question yeah
there's no second question I mean that
is a really big
that's a really big statement to make
and it was just
oh okay it's like they it's like the the
the there was no follow-up or or they
already knew this and they didn't have
to follow up because I was shocked when
I heard that it's like when the military
has in their daily flight flight
briefings that a a a frequent warning
that yeah uaps are operating in the area
so be careful what
them like was that that was happening
you know in like U.S airspace over
LaGuardia or something or Heathrow in
the UK I mean it's just like that would
be big [__] news but here now if
there's uaps out there today be careful
I think I think them classifying these
things as uaps
uh has
basically meant they can push things
onto the under the rug a bit Yeah the
UAP is unexplaned aerial phenomena
rather than another
UFO is very synonymous with aliens UAP
could just mean anything
too it could be a Russian a Russian like
fighter they've never seen a Chinese fan
that they've never seen but then it
could also be aliens
I think them calling them uaps
you never really know what they're
talking about no so they can brush it
under the carpet a little bit the same
thing with UFO it could be anything
yeah
um I can't think of the word off top of
my head
um but wouldn't it be self-absorbent of
us to think that we're the most
intelligent life in the universe yeah
it's that I agree with that thank you so
much for the contribution Captain
um
the room and I'm on my own
David Bailey makes a point here that my
first question how do you travel through
the radiation belts I think it means the
Van Allen belts there's not actually
that much radiation in the van Allen
belts we travel through them so um we
went to the moon traveled to the violin
belts um as long as you hit them at the
right angle sort of thing and go quickly
enough you don't you're not very far the
only time the Van Allen belts are a
little bit dangerous is if you were to
some reason stay in them yeah
or if there's solar
um
solar activity the radiation levels do
Spike quite badly but
um
or a reaction control system to keep you
in a stationary uh orbit and and
continuous with the movement of the or
the the location of the Van Allen belt
um
uh so would it be would it be Thruster
here for us to hear both go at the same
time so you don't move
well once you get into a certain
position right and stable you should be
good you're good yeah no you still may
be traveling let's say you know like the
the solar system is traveling through
the Galaxy you know you're still
relative to the gravity well in the Sun
so you just get there you match your
speed to keep yourself at the van inside
the Van Allen belt so you can cook like
a possum
space anchor yeah yeah you just and you
know we we uh we do that with a lot of
things you know like um the James Webb
Space Telescope Is Anchored In A
LaGrange point I think it's LaGrange too
all right we're we're uh uh between two
laws of objects isn't it and it just
sits there and then so it sits because
it's pulled between the two something so
yeah uh the solar we've got a big solar
um Observatory that's sort of sit in one
of those gravity points as well
somewhere that just looks at the sun
that's all it does this looks at the Sun
um only thing you have to do is negate
your vector according to wherever you
want to be
sounds
thank you
what the [__] that's why I said super
simple right after I'm wearing a cowboy
hat I understand
[Laughter]
but um yeah that might be interesting
but um I I just I think aliens let's go
back to the question earlier we said
like why would aliens come here as well
though I always thought that life might
or Advanced big life might not be that
um common
so we might just be like at the end of
the day if we started exploring the
universe and we found another planet
with some monkeys on it we go all the
time and we do research and we'd do
tasks and we'd you know we'd be
interested I've got to think we go to
the Serengeti on holiday all the time
now to go and look at the giraffe
alien life would come here and look at
the big stupid pink things thinking
they're clever you know it's just like
you think about like the kardashev scale
we're not even a type one planet oh yeah
we we're like yeah like
or is
obviously in relation to how long we've
been in the universe we probably are
just so
we think we're Advanced because we're
the cleverest we've ever been in our
history we think we're Advanced but
we're probably not
our nearest neighbor who might have been
here 100 million years longer than us
well expanding on that one thing um
I believe why why does a lot of people
think it's Centric to the United States
as much I don't think it is but our
ability to record and the power of the
U.S military to intercede and collect
and interact is probably second to no
one else on the planet
so uh we have
admittedly we have lots of Air Base lots
of bases here in the uh in the United
States that's devoted to
[__] that no one else need that they
don't want to know about you know um
Area 51 S4 hell even wright-patterson's
got secret [__] going on that's uh part
of the UFO phenomenal opposite him right
Patterson isn't it isn't that what
darpa's mean the skunks works is as well
they're darpa's everywhere but it's the
darker projects yeah it's the the
is it right
um yeah
okay again thank you so much for the
contribution captain and by the way
Harris I wish I could prove it but you
look like you could be a younger version
of me if not my baby brother oh I'll
take it does that make me like Colonel
caveman
yeah
no because that's that's wrong
directions
um I like playing with my privates
caveman
um probably so it's not wearing pants I
don't think
oh back to 10 inch
um I I just wondered do you do what do
you guys think then do you think let's
talk about disclosure really quickly
then do you actually think we are living
in a world that is going to will we see
disclosure basically in our lifetimes
that actually the government will come
out and say yes
we are being visited by alien life or
non-human life
is it possible
[Music]
it may be a slow trickle or just maybe
you know
big sudden thing that you know the
president stands in a a competent
president would stand on a Podium and
just lay it all out
hmm
I'd love to be in a in a time period
where
where aliens were common knowledge and
we could
study
learn about it
I don't think that's going to happen in
our lifetime well you will get the
acknowledgment that they exist okay okay
I don't think we're going to meet them
or we're going to see them or have any
real proof of them other than the
government saying that they exist for a
really long time
with that thought
do you think with with obviously
since human history has been a thing
we've been talking about aliens two
would agree at some point there could be
a history of aliens visiting this planet
but what about the deal are you all
familiar with the Dark Forest
kind of how we may be in a dark forest
in space how we're on like the edge of a
forest and maybe everybody else is on
the other end of that forest and wait
they have to go through a force to get
to us what if I'm just spitballing uh we
have had visitors on this planet or
anything of the sort over time and yada
yada but they have to go to that dark
force it's difficult to get to to us and
what if now over the last couple hundred
years
whatever that how time works and all
these other different places that's for
their them you know not for us whatever
we might get there one day uh
uh could
it kind of be coming to a head in the
same way like yes our technology and and
the internet's here so we're all talking
about it a hell of a lot more than we've
ever been able to and it's like much
more in the Forefront of our uh thought
processes than it typically is I guess
especially as like a whole as a species
yeah
it comes to a head as a species since
we're we're all listening and talking to
it globally I mean currently globally
we're literally on different sides of
the world it's just having this
conversation should we go to governments
across the world and say
essentially F off show us this if you're
gonna if we know you have information
that you aren't showing us don't show it
to us in 50 years when it's Declassified
we run this stuff show us now
how long did it take us to admit that we
gave syphilis to the uh Tuskegee Airmen
you're not allowed to watch YouTube when
you're stoned anymore all right
what's in YouTube when you're stoned all
right that's the only way I watch
YouTube my mate he was he honestly once
said to me and we were talking about all
this conspiracies
um
yeah mermaids are real
I'm sorry
that's on a document
documents on the Discovery Channel
Damien no sit down what are you talking
about but then I Googled it and he was
right there was a documentary on Animal
Planet about how mermaids are real and
it included a a video of somebody
running around a log and there's a
mermaid there and on planet got sued
loads for it they got they got really
toppled off for it all right it was
supposed to be a joke but they didn't
tell me not it was a joke and but my
mate was half watching it stoned
believed it and he believed it for years
until he's told me and I went sit down
no more watching TV when you're stoned
inside
and it's it's true and there's so much
perfect I just had a thought it's it
there's an argument to be made that
um the governments will never tell us
um about aliens
especially if those aliens are a threat
to us
simply because we are a very very noisy
planet
we have radio signals that they don't
just live on earth they'll go out into
space
so if they start telling
information about these aliens those
aliens might not like it and they might
hear it one day and come and kill us
that's an argument to be made because
they can't they can't stop a radio wave
from leaving the planet can't stop the
radio wave Mal
so it's not the signal now
um the thing is though at the end at the
moment
aliens they cannot admit if UFOs
genuinely are visiting the Earth they
can't admit it because the main thing we
pay our taxes for is defense they meet
like half of our budget goes on defense
um it's it's a or it's not not quite
that much in this country but it's a big
chunk of our thing so if UFOs are coming
in and out of our airspace and they
cannot do a damn thing about it
then we're going to go away we paying
you
why are we paying all these taxes if you
can't protect us what's the point of
view and that will always be the point
until and this is I can't remember who
who suggested this but he basically the
argument was look the the our
governments will pretend there's an
ideological threat in in communism and
when that stops working there will be a
terrorist threat that we have to then
have a war on terror and when that stops
working there'll be an alien threat and
you need to pay us our taxes because we
need to protect you from these aliens
and whether that's faked or real I gotta
admit that I'm there going
yeah if I was in charge that's what I do
as well yeah I mean it's pretty logical
yeah these aliens they come from the
planet over there
yeah prove it uh yeah you can go there
if you want I can't get there oh well
you just have to take our words for it
then
um if you think that governments aren't
hiding technologies that are super
Advanced then I don't know what to say
it's the way of the government they hide
crap from us
I don't think they trust us and thank
you for the contribution Kerry
just to go off of what you said Jeff
rabecky said something a couple minutes
ago that he's not sure if governments
would acknowledge aliens because it
would go against religious beliefs I
think they would for the The Fear Factor
for the hey if if your religion's not
helping you guess who can
they would just claim that Jesus was an
alien this yeah here's this alien his
name is Jesus
but you can call him Jesus yeah and he
has long hair he's green but you know
ignore that
he is Jesus he this is his second coming
or third coming whatever you want
however they'd sell us this is going to
be an inappropriate joke are you ready
I'm so ready for it man let her rip
companies like Ann Summers or whatever
the American version of Ann Summers is
in the US will just start selling
anti-probing devices
um today we call them butt plugs but in
the future it'll be an anti-alien
probing device and that's not it'll be
like 50 Quid there'll be an LED in there
that flashes and so it vibrates as well
oh I want to flash England it should
still working every so often it's still
working I'm not getting probed
I'm making a stupid joke but
they will sell us crap about it
will it'll be cool to think aliens are
real wow Alf viewing view of guys will
go through the roof
um if an alien isn't Advanced enough to
take you from your bed without walking
through your door they're they're more
advanced to take a butt plug out
because they really wanted to get you
hashtag broke the cattle Resort in probe
for this one send it back
I want an unproved one
that they've got like x-ray vision and
they can see you and you're you're
having fun time with your partner and
they go oh look he's already probing
that one
just watching that scene from the
interview just
hmm
and it was proved on blah blah
it's like there's a library card right
oh this has been broken this one is you
haven't turned your probed alien your
probe human back on time if you've got a
library fee Matt just on your space
Jesus Point real quick y'all remember
when like AI was the whole thing you
know we're not when it was a whole thing
but Eric oh God uh you know when like AI
like photos of yourself was a big thing
and all that like six months ago one of
the ones I had straight up made me look
like space Jesus Jesus
it cracked me up is that your Texas
Jesus one or the other hey I'll take
that one actually no they're too
religious I I that would be you know too
much to like no I I don't need that one
Jesus was just high all the time
damn right I'm walking on water no Jesus
that's a problem
you just I've got one fish and one loaf
of bread and I'm gonna feed all of us
and then just sits our stoned eating
fish and it was just him can we can we
do like a animated Bible series of just
Stone jeans oh my God Is Heaven yes
we're getting we're gonna get letters
um but never mind we're gonna get
letters who sends letters
some nasty emails maybe easy nasty
emails I get so occasionally not often
but occasionally
um I get oh I got I got really mean like
when I did the conspiracy Mystery
Channel oh I got death threats it was
not good
um
but yeah so
video masks on how to test your math
your mask for Kobe
you got a lot of crap for that but um
but yeah I think
we're joking about that but honestly
people will try and sell us crap
if they ever get Advanced they will
um and and our government will use it
for their benefit because they always do
I don't I don't go for a lot of these
covid myths and things that people
knocked around I'm like no a lot of the
stuff they put in was trying to protect
human lives that's what they were
actually trying to do there's loads of
these things and but but can we say that
I really do that
he just wants to lie in his own Pockets
well yeah but a lot of big companies and
governments did take advantage of the
covert situation of course they did
because that's what big companies do
they just they sit around going can we
make money out of this and to be honest
the government did it but so did every
every like random Joe on the internet
like people were selling custom masks
it's exactly the same thing as if like
and his wife and whatever they they gave
masks to people but the random Joe was
selling these custom masks on Etsy
making money from it but that's
fine
when we we had these um
bailout programs these bailout loans
here in the United States
and you know for companies you know to
help make you know so they can make it
through the pandemic and it turns out
that a lot of the politicians that
signed that law got millions of dollars
of loans and then they forgave the loans
and so they pocketed a lot of it our the
Congress that we have
approved was trillion some dollars was
it
Harris do you remember it was like 10
billion of on or something in the UK I
mean it was like imagine trillions in
America and so so yeah and so then all
the the uh the congressmen and the
Senators
they line up to take all of those loans
and then oh well we don't want to have
to pay him back
and there and some of these guys have
millions of dollars of loans it's just
free money that they voted them
themselves
and because of the pandemic so yeah even
the politicians
oh it's just it's disgusting it really
is I mean how many schools could we have
built with all that [__] money that
Congress put in their own pot literally
their own checking account well look I
mean even after 9 11 the government used
that to again a lot of big companies
like Raytheon stuff made a crapload of
money out of it
um but the governments took away a lot
of our freedoms a lot of our basic
rights
You could argue that they took advantage
of the situation
did it again aliens they would do it
again
alien tax
you know Trump was already been arguing
against that I know but um you know
we're gonna try and build a wall against
it but I mean they'll be they'll be an
alien tax in the that we now need a
space force and you're gonna have to pay
for it
you know and
let's go
um and you know it's just I mean we've
already we've already got one but it's
it's it's the way the law it's the way
the world is
we're all good
um anti-probing tax
you need yeah and that's just
anti-programming against the government
yeah
I know we already have a space for so
but you know they you know I mean they
would be there would have to be some
sort of we'd have to have a response
that we'd have to then pay for
um what does space force actually do
because they don't go into space What do
they do
um they they protect us
um
what happened was the Air Force had a
uh they have what was it called the uh
they had a it's called space command
and it was uh I think in Wyoming that
was just monitoring satellites it was uh
making sure you know um they also their
biggest job was to track uh space debris
but uh for whatever reason Trump thought
that one Air Force Department needed to
be its own branch of service so we could
and and then he had to fund it and I
think you know on the outside it looks
like it was a boondoggle to pay off more
Senators more congressmen to get more
uh [__] spent in their District you know
but essentially it all space force was
space command inside the Air Force
it was partly I believe the Air Force
basically and we don't want to do this
job anymore with the Air Force you know
and they were saying it was a nice way
as well for the Air Force to sort of
actually re
they said look we've got this budget
we're having to spend a big chunk of it
doing all this space stuff we don't want
to do it so there's a bit of an argument
about well the Navy you don't want to do
it and the Army don't so that so they
sort of okay well we'll create a
separate
organization to do it but yeah the main
thing is they seem to be trying but also
I suppose there's China starts shooting
around a few of our satellites they deal
with that sort of thing and supposed to
be defense and stuff and and but
eventually the idea is to have a
fighting force in space no generally and
that's what the Americans do because
everybody else sort of went I'm pretty
sure we've got treaties that saying not
allowed to do that and the Americans are
there going space
America's been America's been breaking
the treaties since its Inception you
know we I mean every treaty with the
indigenous people you know the Native
Americans oh we broke all those
I mean you know cluster bombs yeah [__]
that [__] I mean it is breaking American
breaking our International treaties is
part of American culture oh there's a
place that doesn't have a gun well we
got to go shoot a rocket up there that
has guns on it because oh my God what
happens if something happens and you
know and all right and all right go
holy [__]
I'm British you all know weird hippies
when it comes to guns I love guns I love
guns I just don't want my neighbor to
have one because he is clearly an idiot
um so you know I I love guns guns are
cool
um I just I just don't want everyone
else to have one
all right guys
I think we've covered that aliens aren't
true uh so don't worry about it and if
they are true
just buy a butt plug I think that's
basically what we've decided in this
video hashtag probe the cattle
um
that sounded like a cockadoodledoo thing
what was that who has a rooster
probe the cattle and immediately set up
the cockrells
um guys thank you so much for the
application as always it's been
absolutely fascinating and funny
um I gotta asked a comment you know I
did a video on this a couple of years
ago talking about this and I I got a bit
sarcastic in it and I have two messages
going if you're not part of the solution
you're part of the problem
why are you being so cheeky why are you
being so silly sent by such an important
thing and I'm like oh please God I hope
he's not watching this video
because we've just talked about butt
plugs for about 10 minutes
and so yeah but um there is a serious
conversation there to have I just
I don't know what the answer is at the
moment and I'm just like thinking yeah
there's lots of interesting stuff out
there there's a lot of crap right there
not really the the type the kind of
people that can answer it seriously
we're not scientists we're not I mean
story kind of is but it better be
that's that's me
here it goes
on the internet can't actually come up
with a decent like thing it's always
going to just be commentary isn't it
for the uh matches come up with a really
good you know
uh idea or what if
one of the problems with disclosure is
it's just not one species
well there there was
Sammy's like damn it what what what what
what
but
how would the government make any kind
of like disclosure response
when there may be
four or five alien races that are all
different maybe have different agendas
or dozens or hundreds
what is the and I'm not trying to um
to um
play oh poor government
but what if that is one of the key
issues is they have no clue on how to
manage any of that because there's too
many players in the game
yeah
extra dimensional beings that's a whole
different conversation yeah that's a you
know that's that's a whole different
kettle of fish yeah so how do they
manage it I mean at least from repeat
well
or whatever and and then there's the the
Grays and then there's the Pleiadians
and then I mean it just can you imagine
trying to unload all of that on the
American people in one speech
is we always think that like one alien
race they're benevolent in there like
another one there malevolent in there
not to be trusted all draconians they
eat babies and I said and I'm like no
Humanity's not like that you could have
a million different we could have five
ships come from Earth and one ship is
just an exploration vessel one ship is
actually after resources one ship is
there to steal your babies once you know
what I mean it depends on what they what
that person wants or whatever they think
and yeah there's no morals and another
one is like led by Christians and they
just wanna they wanna sell you a Bible
the aura agendas
if any aliens come down and start
preaching the book of origin run run run
run run run as Jesus saved your life
no have you heard the good news no no no
no
the only good news here is the high is
going to be 70 degrees
I know they had a fight with the guy
that knocked my door once again have you
heard the good news
well no he's in America I had a I had a
baby yeah the baby screaming right and I
opened the door and I sort of said oh
and normally I love talking to Young's
Witnesses and things but he was a
missionary and I'm like it's a bit of
African I'm supposed to come to British
where the hell are you in the UK I've
got I've got running water and a
flushing toilet what the hell are you
doing here there's four churches around
the next three blocks go yeah exactly I
can I can throw a stone and hit a mosque
I said I can throw a rock in here to
church of England church because they
aren't they've got no arms they're just
like oh you can't insult us huh yeah I
just did
um
but but my point it's baby screaming I'm
really sorry man I can't talk right now
and you're just like no no and this is
really really important and you know
Jesus and I'm like no really I can't
talk I want to shut the door and this
little prick put his foot in the door
and went if you really think your baby
crying is more important than your soul
and I didn't really harder than that
he was wearing you know he's like the
shirt and a tie so I'd use the tie as a
way of getting his attention and get
your foot out of my door and now and so
and and shut the door and I was so angry
I didn't want to punched the baby no I
didn't
um but you know it's just like I don't
know if the Rock and the mark garment or
the baby
[Music]
rocking the mask and a bunch of baby
um
I never realized you were sorry
the only one mosque I've ever been to I
was I was at school right it really
stuck with me
um we have a obviously a strong
um history with India
our country something and um so I went
to a mosque and it was um a sea cross
and in the bit that we were allowed to
go in because we're not obviously six
um there's a bit in the front and all
the way around was photos from like
um their dads and their granddads and
things wearing British uniform and they
fought
in World War one and World War II and
all the way through I'm thinking
people are actually racist towards Asian
people in this country we've got
horrible names for them they're proud to
be British than than the rest was put
together how the hell are we giving
these people
mostly about a raise
they're more proud to be British than I
am and so that always just sat in there
it's not a racism even at that age I
thought racism stupid
you know I'm just stupid
um it's like you know uh uh people here
in America you know immigrants
but like you know immigrants here in
America they are more gung-ho about
being Americans and Americans that were
naturalized and were born here well more
about America than people are just more
the the whole you have five years before
you can become a citizen you have to
take a certain like test and pass this
like American citizen standard whatever
whatever every single person that's ever
passed that test knows 10 times the
amount of American history that anybody
that's been through American history in
high school in any state in the U.S has
been through or knows we know more about
American history than most Americans but
it's so bad that's true
um anyway thank you so much
um
uh you made me think of another question
this story but I'm not gonna say it
because you go for it no you do it on
purpose spell it
um don't
I'm not gonna do I'm not gonna do it so
anyway thank you so so much we are going
saying goodbye this time an hour and a
half is enough
um we solve nothing but and we're glad
we're very proud we solve nothing three
of us out of four have beards and we
still didn't manage to to prove anything
um we proved that Jesus was probably an
alien or Texan
our Texan
are you the alien all right then right
hashtag probe the cattle yeah my wife's
gonna kill me but
um
right well you got the ancient alien
Theory I know this isn't even Storm's
fault this was your fault
aliens spill it obviously we're Stargate
fans right yeah yes I know charity of
the Gods was God
[Music]
email that
yeah but that's basically what I said
he's just trying to steal my thunder
um but is that true then are we thinking
that is is it possible that alien life
visited the Earth interacted with the
cavemen possibly probed them and but
that's a whole Evolution question
um and then we got a lot of our
mythology comes from is that possible
yeah
or maybe there was just some um someone
from the other side of the planet who
had a little bit more information who
such as decided to pretend to be their
God my favorite thing is Christopher
Columbus like
was an [__] he went to this island
and wanted their stuff and they said no
and he went right
but and he knew there was going to be an
eclipse that and the moon was going to
turn red like a week later and if you do
not give me your stuff I'm gonna my God
is gonna make the moon disappear
and turn it red and they were all just
like ah whatever and then it happened
and they gave him they gave him their
[__] and he was a dick and his pictures
of him like the pictures of him with all
these natives like bound to him as if
he's a god
maybe it's just like situations like
that let me throw in another book
recommendation in terms of you know
backing up Christopher Columbus was a
dick uh the the uh you can uh get a book
of Christopher Columbus's ships logs of
what he wrote about his voyages and his
impressions of the people the indigenous
that he ran into
it is absolutely disgusting what I mean
what that [__] wrote down Christopher
Columbus is a dick he wrote it himself I
mean so it's on Amazon Christopher
Columbus I can't remember the exact
title of the publisher Christopher
Columbus's ships adult ship's logs and
it is from his own hand
an indictment against it
I'm the sword alien he saw UFO on the
voyage over
it's it's one of the first the records
one of the first
um references of a UFO scientist is his
writings
because he was a dick yeah
the Malaysian air flight that went
missing
went back in time and that's what he
said what happened
totally reasonable
MH370 that's it because it landed on
Christopher Columbus's oh no that
wouldn't work because then he wouldn't
have got there but he thought oh my God
it's a dragon and I was like no it's not
a dragon it's just a plane
yeah
did you just watch Indiana Jones no that
was actually your manifest
all right we are out of here guys thank
you so so much
um we will be back next week talking
about more silliness if you want us to
talk about stuff like this and not just
science fiction every week
anything you want us to ever talk about
please get into the comments science
fiction science faction oh man that's
good
that's really good we'll probably be
back with some sort of I would be it'll
be my last video next week for at least
a couple of weeks because I'm going on
my holidays I'm not going to be a
network here I'm also on my holidays
American takeover hashtag probe the
cattle
how about next week we do our top 10
movies I don't think Matt wants to do
that video because he's never seen die
hard so die hard I've seen Predator have
you have you no
thank you
right it's so good
um but um I've watched the character
Predator is that the same thing
so what am I on it no
yeah so next week we're going to do our
strike survival guide and we'll do top
10. we'll do one of the top 10 movie
things we were talking about so that's
next week
um
horrendous weapons like aliens are
actually real and then we'll be talking
about that obviously or Harris gets
probed because he's going to Vegas
tomorrow so anything can happen oh
anything will happen yeah probe the
cattle
um yeah say goodbye everybody goodbye
everyone goodbye
foreign